First, as far as methods are concerned, where do the methods come from?
One obvious source is the operations in our analysis model.
In addition to the specific services provided, there are signals, okay, and
there maybe actions, activities, and
events in any behavior model such as state charts.
We also have to make sure that we're signing those operations in the form of
methods to particular classes.
In addition to those that come directly from the analysis model, there's others
we should always be aware might need to be included in our classes.
You should include constructors and destructors, getters and
setters,copy constructors, printers or,
or methods that construct string versions of the data inside of a class.
Selectors, if you have, complex data,
how you're going to take out the pieces of it.
And, any kind of, iterators if you have,
if your class has more than one, you know, is a collection class of some sort.
How are you going to provide the elements of that collection.
It's not necessarily the case that every class has to have all of these methods,
but you should be aware of the possibility of their existence so
you can determine early on whether or not that you need to define them